foreign
they say a week is a long time in
politics but right now just 24 hours is
these Tory councilors in Darlington
rapidly losing patience with the
never-ending changes in policy and
personnel
Bedlam I think it's absolute turmoil
it's disheartening we're listening to
people on a daily basis about their
frustrations about what's happening and
I think you know what my hope is now is
that they're going to sort it out
only one member of the group backed Liz
trust for leader but they all agree that
now is not the right time to replace her
it's the shambles if I'm if I'm honest
she's got to get her MPS coalescing
around her and it's just clearly not
happening that's what's causing all the
issues at the minute but what is a
political crisis for the conservatives
is the cost of living crisis for the
country as inflation continues to soar
for many here the main concern is not
who is in power but what's in their
pockets because for more and more people
just making ends meet is already
becoming a major struggle
but darlington's indoor market there's
150 years of history but Shoppers are
concerned only about the future we're
going to end up where we're going to
need two jobs
like just to to live really you're
literally scrimming and Square open just
to buy milk bread and your Essentials I
mean I'm only eating one meal a day one
meal a day yeah because it's just too
too expensive yes it is
Robin Blair has been a Trader here for
70 years but has never seen prices rise
so steeply it's so uncertain you just
don't know where it's going to end at
and and how it's going to affect people
would you want to see more support from
the government yes definitely I think
they've got to have to support I mean
we're all just it was looking a bit
better a week ago but now it's all up in
the air again
the only certainty tough times ahead for
politicians and the public Ivor Bennett
Sky News Darlington